j'ai votre place ok moi j'ai commandé la
course
j'ai commandé la course en fait donc
voilà vous mettez pas mais vous vous
mettez pas mes affaires alors clairement
le gars alors donc
tu peux pas me fumer
tu vas [__] mon téléphone
Ruby nicara qui est avec nous euh c'est
quoi ton prénom mon vrai nom
[Rires]
c'est quoi ton vrai prénom alors mon
vrai prénom je m'appelle vraiment Ruby
en fait oui c'est vrai mais par contre
nicara non c'est pas mon vrai nom c'est
ça
j'ai pensé à rubinicaro rubinicara Aya
Nakamura
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors bon ça va mieux ah tu m'as copié
tu as fait des tatouages j'adore ça te
va bien
ça va merci
comme moi et tout on adore
s'il te plaît tu connais mon père toi
c'est mon médecin traitant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
64 en réalité c'est de parler de ces
sujets là en fait que les Français sont
usés par le travail et moi autant
qu'influenceuse après on va certains
vont dire oui mais tu es mal placé tu
gagnes de l'argent mais j'ai pas grandi
avec une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche il y a un moment donné moi je me
mets à la place des Français et c'est
vrai je comprends pourquoi ils sont
révoltés je suis parti
pour voilà
rugby présidente
[Applaudissements]
alors en gros je vais vous expliquer un
peu ce qui s'est passé alors donc du
coup en fait j'ai commandé donc un
Hubert et donc j'ai mis du temps pour
descendre parce qu'en fait je cherchais
ma carte bancaire et j'ai mis du donc
j'ai mis du temps pour descendre et donc
du coup bah je suis montée donc dans le
véhicule et c'était rien passé jusqu'à
un moment il commence à mal me parler à
être impoli avec moi mais du coup moi
j'ai pas compris en fait donc du coup je
lui dis monsieur calmez-vous je
comprends pas pourquoi vous me parlez
comme ça déjà vous me parlez pas comme
ça pas sur ce temps je suis une cliente
j'ai pas fait du stop donc je suis une
cliente vous me parlez pas comme ça donc
je précise bien qu'on roulait parce
qu'il y en a plein qui pense que il
avait annulé la course et que et que
donc et donc du coup on suit donc à un
moment il commence à me dire de
descendre et moi donc du coup je me je
lui ai dit non je descends je descends
pas parce que je suis pas arrivé à
destination et c'est vrai que j'ai
commencé un peu à paniquer parce que je
me suis retrouvée voilà une femme toute
seule face à ce chauffeur en train de
m'agresser verbalement je me suis dit à
tout moment en fait il va te frapper
donc du coup pour pour le déstabiliser
je me suis dit pourquoi pas lancer enfin
pour me protéger le déstabiliser je me
suis dit bah pourquoi pas lancer un live
un live Instagram voilà
et donc du coup bah après un moment
je lui dis non
je suis désolé pourquoi
on était en train de rouler ça faisait
10 minutes qu'on roulait et donc à un
moment il commence à s'arrêter en plein
milieu d'une route et il me dit de
descendre et moi je suis désolé je suis
cliente j'ai payé une course c'est pour
arriver à destination c'est pas pour
descendre comme ça au milieu du jeu
et que j'étais en retard c'est ce qui
m'avait dit quoi bah alors en fait le
problème c'est qu'il était il était mal
poli parce que justement en fait alors
je vous explique comment ça s'est passé
il m'a dit Constitution
imaginons pour qui donc
au bout de quelques minutes
en fait il s'est énervé il était remonté
contre moi parce que j'étais en retard
et moi je dis qu'il me paraît qu'il a
pas à m'engueuler en fait il commençait
à mal me parler mais gratuitement je
l'avais rien fait ou pas bah après
peut-être qu'il m'a reconnu ça je sais
pas ça je peux pas le garantir
je précise que de base ça se passe super
bien parce que moi je prends souvent je
prend régulièrement des des huberts et
ça se passe vraiment super bien je
m'entends super bien avec les chauffeurs
je rigole avec eux il y en a ils me
reconnaissent je respecte les chauffeurs
déjà j'ai pas que ça à faire à mon
prendre à un chauffeur au contraire en
fait les incivilités non et donc du coup
voilà moi je respecte ce métier je sais
que c'est un métier compliqué etc les
chauffeurs s'engue rarement gratuitement
en général c'est qu'il y a une raison
puis la raison c'est que j'étais en
retard et en fait il a voulu se défouler
sur moi
vous êtes excusé de votre retard au
départ au départ vous n'avez rien vu en
fait moi j'ai pas trop compris parce que
il parlait fort avec un accent et j'ai
pas trop compris il était mal poli il
était un peu il était super mal poli moi
je comprenais pas trop ce qu'il disait
et donc du coup bah il y a un moment je
lui ai dit mais de se calmer en fait
tout simplement
je suis une cliente
il y a la version du chauffeur et le
chauffeur lui il dit que vous lui avez
parlé les gens par exemple savez-vous
qui je suis je suis de la téléréalité
personne me parle comme ça et ensuite et
ensuite il vous a demandé mais arrêtez
de me filmer je veux pas être filmé vous
allez porter de la diffamation c'est
faux c'est de la diffamation c'est
complètement faux alors faut savoir que
moi quand j'ai commencé donc les réseaux
sociaux alors déjà moi la téléréalité
m'a approché j'ai toujours refusé je
déteste la télé-réalité je suis une
artiste donc jamais donc déjà sur ce non
mais c'est vrai
donc déjà là c'est pas crédible c'est
pas crédible parce que je suis contre la
téléréalité je déteste la télé-réalité
donc jamais je dirais non mais vous
m'avez prise pour qui euh
vous étiez agent immobilier
la dernière fois l'acheter vendait des
immeubles à Dubaï ouais
et donc du coup
d'ailleurs en ce moment je suis en train
d'écrire des sons
comme ça juste parce que justement je
suis une fille un peu rappeuse pas
politiquement correcte qu'il y en a qui
qui sont clairement pour le chauffeur en
fait déjà on agresse pas les femmes on
agresse pas les femmes on est en France
on est dans un pays où la femme la femme
n'agresse pas les hommes non plus les
femmes n'agressent pas les hommes non
plus je dis pas ça je dis je dis c'est
réciproque
alors donc du coup moi j'ai lancé un
live j'ai bien fait attention de ne de
ne pas le filmer donc déjà c'est lui qui
a pris mon téléphone qui s'est filmé
tout seul donc il arrache mon téléphone
voilà ce téléphone là d'ailleurs il a
cassé ma caméra oui il a cassé ma caméra
si tu veux le montrer après
[Rires]
charmant
donc déjà on a ça c'est l'agression je
suis désolé c'est une agression on a on
n'arrive pas le téléphone des femmes
vidéo complémentaire on va voir une
vidéo complémentaire une vidéo complète
qui a été filmée par un passant regardez
le film
elle a commandé elle était en retard
j'ai dit mais madame vous êtes en retard
ça fait 5 minutes je vous attends là je
voulais annuler course même je vais
partir
alors
Gilles Verdez
je vous aime beaucoup et j'admire votre
distinction et là vous êtes pas reconnu
en fait déjà je tiens à préciser que
vous voulez plus me rendre des
téléphones il voulait se taper mon
téléphone parce qu'il avait mis mon
téléphone donc dans sa poche et vous
voulez plus me le rendre j'étais obligé
de le récupérer de force la vidéo je
pense vous voulez passer
on vous sent au bout de votre vie
il m'avait mis il m'avait mis hors de
moi mais je pense que n'importe qui
aurait réagi comme ça je suis désolé en
même temps tu me prends mon téléphone
mais encore une fois c'est tout pour le
buzz j'ai beaucoup robinicara mais là on
a l'impression que tu as besoin de ton
drama de la semaine j'ai pas besoin de
cette fille tu avais besoin de ton drama
de la semaine pour faire quelques vues
et arrêter de taper sur les chauffeurs
uber c'est des mecs qui travaillent
comme des chiens qui gagnent une misère
alors parfois il y a des dérapages mais
là clairement on voit que c'est toi qui
agressive et autre chose arrêtez arrêtez
de filmer en permanence
tu aimes les choses
est-ce que tu es d'accord
avec des chauffeurs jamais jamais jamais
assis d'accord
chauffeur chauffeur si tu es champion
a pu appuyer sur le champignon
de tout filmer en permanence c'est pas
parce que toi tu te mets en scène tout
le temps qu'il faut l'imposer aux autres
la vie c'est pas les Marseillais en fait
le mec il a le droit de pas vouloir être
filmé c'était pour le déstabilisé parce
que je me suis dit qu'il a à tout moment
il va me frapper
en live ça va peut-être le faire fuir
oui bien sûr j'ai eu peur le gars il
faisait 2 m il était hyper agressif il
était hyper violent après fallait être
enfin pour le coup faut le vivre aussi
ça donc
Guillaume mais je trouve que c'est un
peu un procès d'intention parce que ce
prétexte que c'est rubis toi tu tombes
en plein dedans et tu dis en gros ouais
tu cherches pour le buzz quand on filme
les gens qui sont harcelés par exemple
qui sont tabassés à l'école là tu dis
pas à chaque fois
je vais vous dire pourquoi
[Musique]
les images en guise de preuves ok pour
montrer à la police ok il en a refusé
qui viennent témoigner parce qu'ils ont
filmé les chaises
tu as diffusé le mec qui travaille là
mon téléphone en l'occurrence on le voit
sur les rubis et cette magnifique c'est
pas du tout parce que sur lui en plus je
l'aime bien Bobby mais c'est cette manie
de filmer les gens en permanence
un autre exemple arrête t'es
insupportable et insupportable on a reçu
le la personne aveugle qui était venue
ici qui a eu un problème avec un
chauffeur il a filmé il est passé pas un
influenceur qu'est-ce que tu racontes et
ça nous a permis ça nous a permis de
voir la scène donc tu dis n'importe quoi
tu dis n'importe quoi
j'ai des amis qui ont des qui ont des
qui ont des filles des jeunes filles
si tu sens qu'il y a un problème tu
prends ton téléphone
on ne filme pas les gens rugby
calme-toi Guillaume ça veut dire que la
prochaine fois ça va être la porte à
quoi en fait la prochaine étape c'est
quoi la porte ouverte
c'est la porte à quoi
tu as raison c'est la porte à quoi
ça la prochaine fois mais je vais aller
dans un magasin ma carte elle passe pas
on va pas m'arracher la carte on va
mettre une jupe voilà
après ça va être quoi
ça va être quoi l'escalade
[Applaudissements]
tu es très malhonnête intellectuellement
il serait elle se réveille le matin elle
dit bon alors j'ai vendu l'eau de mon
bain j'ai vendu mes petites culottes
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien pouvoir faire
exprès
tu devrais écouter son rap parce qu'elle
fait un très bon rap et donc c'est quoi
ton son là par exemple on parle de quoi
ton prochain son bah tiens chante
c'est pas une belle voix
[Applaudissements]
prochaine fois très bien
pourquoi pas mais la prochaine fois je
viens et je fais un freestyle très bien
[Rires]
il est arrivé la même chose mais pas
vraiment la même chose mais j'ai eu une
embrouille avec un chauffeur j'étais
tranquillement je venais ici et je dois
passer par la nationale 118 donc c'est
une vraie nationale quoi et tout d'un
coup il me dit excusez-moi mais vous
venez d'annuler la course je suis obligé
de vous de vous faire descendre j'avais
pas annulé la course j'étais en train je
sais même pas faire je lui dis mais
c'est une erreur mais je peux pas il me
dit il faut c'est je suis obligé c'est
comme ça il faut que vous descendiez
il était mais vraiment il voulait il me
dit je vous êtes obligé de descendre je
lui dis mais je m'en fous portez-moi
parce que moi je descendrai pas
un petit peu la troisième
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est pour être beau problème parce que
justement
rubis parce que ils sont c'est normal en
même temps je leur jette pas la pierre
mais comme la course est déjà payé
d'avance
ils sont pas au compteur comme les taxis
donc en fait moi j'ai un problème parce
que je suis au 4e étage sans ascenseur
et quand il fait froid l'hiver je
demande le berge je suis encore à la
maison donc quand il y a que 3 minutes
il faut que je descende à toute vitesse
que je jette le sac poubelle et que je
sorte parce que autrement ils sont
partis
ça fait longtemps
[Applaudissements]
je te souhaite un 118 il a arrêté
les spectateurs qui veulent bien
m'envoyer l'histoire de
là franchement j'ai complètement
décrocher mais alors une force donc
voilà donc Ruby pour toi tu étais
agressive
on commence à qu'on commence à voilà
malgré ses verbalement etc c'est pour
moi ça c'est une agression c'est quoi
comme études après euh j'ai pas fait de
longues études après maintenant
en réalité en vrai c'est pas je sais pas
la première à qui ça arrive il y a
énormément de femmes qui se font
harceler des agressions il y a il y a
des agressions sexuelles il y a des il y
a il y a des kidnappi et regarder
l'émission sur terre
c'est un moment ensemble
ou pas question et là et c'est là où
vraiment il a un départ c'est là où
vraiment il y a un débat c'est
sommes-nous vraiment en sécurité nous
les femmes
qui voulait intervenir
pour avoir la vie en fait de mes abonnés
voilà donc si vous voulez vous pouvez
voter sur mon insta et c'est pas combien
d'avocats
juridique
non je rigole non mais j'ai quelques
avocats
oui voilà
c'est pas drôle c'est que ça fait quoi
toi
c'est quoi ton cursus toi mon cursus
[Rires]
laissez-moi parler avec elle c'est quoi
ton cursus alors moi mon cerveau a
décroché en seconde
[Rires]
dans ma chambre et j'ai toujours aimé
râpé quand j'étais petite et tout je
rappais dans ma chambre complètement
déconnecte
vraiment très écoles après ça fait pas
de moi une demeurée
mais non mais non c'est vrai que j'ai
pas fait de longues études
tous les deux
là tu vas rester un peu oui vas-y
carrément tu as quoi à faire tu sais
quoi ton c'est quoi c'est quoi une
journée type de rubrique j'aimerais bien
savoir tu vois une influenceuse comme ça
tu te réveilles à quelle heure
je me réveille à 10h 11h midi
non c'est juste pour m'amuser avec des
potes et tout on part en boîte et tout
ça de quoi j'étais dans les chiffres
c'est à dire je m'en fous des mecs ouais
bah en vrai je m'en fous des mecs de
base si je mets en boîte c'est vraiment
pour m'amuser avec mes deux copines
voilà simplement et alors et voilà une
journée type rubinkara donc ouais je me
réveille à 11h midi après je fais du
sport
j'écris des sons
je cours voilà je vais aller je vais à
la salle je cours
la journée
quelques jours avant de me trouver un
concept en fait c'est c'est comme
l'autre banc en fait c'était arrivé
quand j'étais quand j'étais dans mon
bain voilà c'est arrivé et voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a un sondage
oui hola
[Applaudissements]
qui est pas connu sur les réseaux je
connais souvent pas connu
on n'est pas connu mais bon
la politiquement correcte etc donc
forcément j'ai beaucoup de haters
non en vrai moi je trouve que je trouve
ça scandaleux vraiment je rêve vraiment
je rêve de je trouve ça scandaleux
justement qu'en normalise ça en fait
c'est c'est pas normal de normaliser de
la violence